everyone this is Steve Andre with
Collider and I am at the Kia Telluride
supper suite at Sundance I want to give
a huge thank you to Kia for being an
awesome sponsor which allows us to
support indie cinema and movies like
this first of all congratulations to
everyone to being part of the Sundance
Film Festival Thank You varial feature
debut sorry so I want to start with
something so this is your future debut
and it's sometimes hard to cast a movie
and I just want to know how how did you
get so many compromising pictures to put
this cast together everything start with
the script and it's like I just focused
like several years just trying to write
the best critic who write and then there
start sharing with my managers agents
and and also had support from the
Sundance Institute the screenplay went
through the sunless labs they were like
phenomena and helped me so much and then
after that just like sending to people
and having people read the script I
think pretty much was like how I started
I have to you do realize I mean there
has to be an element in your brain when
you look around at all these people like
holy F yes yes it's surreal it's it's
it's just amazing believable I hate
asking the generic question but no one
watching this interview or most people
watching this interview will not have
seen the movie yet so how have you been
describing the film to friends it's um
I say it's a drama sci fi and it happens
in this distant reality and we have
interviewers in the interview souls and
and this cells they look like just
people like us but they they never lived
before but they really have like the
hints of their personality like what
they could become if they they are born
or something like that
and so they're there we we show the life
of the the process of all one of those
interviewers during the period of nine
days and this interview during in the
end of this process is going to select
one so to be born and all their other
souls are just going to disappear
it's not heavy at all I have it all no
stakes at all right um for all of you
guys I would imagine that everyone reads
a lot of scripts and there's a lot of
choices and stuff like that
for each of you what was it about this
project in this story the script that
said I I want to be in this well for me
it was just loaded with all these
opportunities right so when I look at a
script I always try to look at the arc
of the character and a major thing for
me is that the character ends in a
different place than Way started and
this movie my character will the
interviewer climbs pretty much a
mountain that's how much she goes
through that's how much change and
transformation and then the other thing
I always think about is how would the
narrative and the impact of the
narrative change because of my body
attached to it if this story was played
by you know 510 white male it would be a
different story
and it's a story that deals with a lot
of intellect and in psychology and
psychiatry and in extension you know
with me being attached it becomes black
psychology and its really powerful
especially being able to see a narrative
dealing with something like that when it
doesn't get dealt with in everyday
mainstream society very much you don't
get to see black bodies being looked at
for the psychology of the person it's
always something physical you know and
it was a really great opportunity in
that way I will say hearing Winston's
voice above you feels like God it's just
this presence is over me I choose you
Tony thank you thank you so much thank
you so much finally I will say that for
me this script was the I'd never read a
script like it
it was truly it's a truly original
script there's a lot of things about it
that are really incredible but that was
one of the first things that struck me
is how original I was
I think there's also something really
cool about world building and creating
new rules and you know a lot of times I
think a script that's exploring that
doesn't I think can miss the emotional
point or kind of you know in in the
attempt to make sure this new place
makes sense and all the rules are
following each other and there's no sort
of holes and I feel like this story
really encapsulated both so it's like
this really fun cool new thing to play
with
as an actor essentially you know these
were all candidates besides Winston's
character and we're new souls that are
experiencing everything for the first
time sort of babies and adult bodies and
so exploring that kind of in sort of not
being a human is sort of is a fun thing
to do while also carrying I think this
caring really great themes and emotional
depth and having arcs for everyone so
it's just a really great story I think
it also allows the audience to kind of
you know root for who who deserves to
live as well you know and that's kind of
fascinating to watch I agree yeah I also
I also agree and I with it with almost
everything and I know everything and
then everything everything everything
that's my character actually I'm very
I'm terrified writer's idea but I felt
his script really hits you like you
first start reading it's like very
intellectual experience you know you're
it's it's fascinating like it's a cool
kind of experiment mind experiment and
then slowly becomes like a heart and at
the end it's a very soulful movie and it
kind of you don't but also a thriller
yeah I was I was flipping through it I
wasn't you know you're laughing and then
you're you're you're surprised and at
the end of it you're probably crying
Tony do Annette well it's it's similar
to a lot of my work so no I I just I I I
really might think is I obviously loved
the script I edited and I facetimed
meeting each other for the first time
and you know you get a vibe from
somebody when you from when you know
you're but when you're about to work
with them and it was just a really
comfortable vibe and here's the thing
we've all been on gigs where you kind of
feel you kind of ask is somebody
captaining the ship like it feels kind
of unsteady and you always I mean I we
always knew that Edson was fully
captaining the show like it was just it
was a really comfortable and it's like
okay someone's got this someone's on
track even though because we as artists
are just kind of like you know we can
get little scatterbrained and just
knowing somebody is at the front is a
huge gift a huge gift a question for you
I'm fascinated by the editing room
because that's the final rewrite I a
list of all directors what maybe
surprised you when you stepped in the
editing room that maybe you weren't
expecting that's a lot of things you
know it's just with so much like I feel
like pretty much you have an idea before
I get to the editing room and I feel
like specially for something like this
in which is a performance based piece
just allowing the performance to to say
what's gonna be the movie what's going
to be the structure of the movie so it
at first I felt like I needs to be like
this but then I'm watching the
performance I so I think that the
performers have to you know guide me in
order to create this this movie rather
than the opposite my follow-up of course
is uh I would imagine that you showed
the movie to some friends and family or
you did some sort of test screening what
did you learn from those early
screenings that impacted the finished
film a lot of stuff we had like a lot of
screenings like I think that Dan or even
more it's funny we weren't invited to
anything but with most of the people who
were not related to the two or have no
idea what the movie was about
because for something that's like as you
know high-concept like this piece you
want someone who's we
watching with fresh eyes that you know
you someone who never read the script or
don't know me or any anyone here can
watch the movie oh I can't understand
the story where I can connect with those
characters and your question was of what
I learned right from them what changes
you might have no change a lot of things
I feel like mostly that it's it's all
about the emotional emotional connection
rather than being intellectual or
looking cool or good because I feel like
there's this [ __ ] it can go in a way
there's this is kind of a there's a
beautiful very you know different
visuals and stuff like that but I think
in the end is more like how if they
don't connect with the characters
doesn't work at all so it was it was
more about how can i added in a way that
they can have more connection with each
character and it was great because also
from from every different person was
watching the movie I learned that they
could identify with different characters
like some people salad like Mike or some
people I like to be like like sander or
cane so it was it was very very
interesting and intriguing this all does
this discusses real people and just like
how can I can add and and show this
features in order to show this people
are alive so I think there's the best
learning from from the process for all
of you guys I would imagine making every
movie or whatever project you're on
there's there's always a day or two that
you'll always remember maybe like just a
fun memory day you really screwed up or
whatever it may be whatever you'd like
to share would you mind sharing
something you'll always remember from
the making of the film
I think we have a scene without giving
you any spoilers but we shot out in the
salt flats some of the characters that
are here and it was I've never been out
of the salt flats before we I mean we
shot the film in Salt Lake City here and
the place itself was just a magical spot
and then we had this really long scene
and we shot in yeah I was like that was
a last night of shooting wasn't it till
about 4:00 was again until like 2:00
3:00 in the morning and it was just it
was like I really remember that of us to
kind of just bonding and this scene was
like what three four pages of just
dialogue more five six yeah and it's
more something yeah we were losing our
minds in a good way the movie shot in
order so all of this yeah so all of this
is essentially as the actor you have
gone through this as the character
you've gone through all the moments that
lead up to this moment that we're
describing and you know it's just
beautiful because you really get to be
there and you're just playing in your
present and it just it was magical and
the landscape of Utah itself added so
much to this movie it was pretty much
the final character so when you read the
script you internalize all these
different things but until you get into
the space until you get into the
landscape
it just wasn't complete and that day it
was complete yeah anything else you guys
1ad
I can't because the I will give a big
spoiler away so I can I can't share I
respect that I agree I that scene I
really enjoyed I think also because a
lot of the candidates don't interact
much in the film we won't have
relationship with well and it was really
fun to like I also have like sort of an
ensemble or like it's a scene with
multiple actors you know and so that was
like a fun thing to play with and I'd
say one of my other memorable moments
which I can't really talk about because
it would give away the film but it was
also filmed out in the salt flats like
outside and that was with me and Winston
and I'd say that was one of the most
connected and sort of like fulfilling
and like muse guided sort of experience
I think I've had like in my professional
career which is really special yeah so
how much who I was gonna say who paid
you five bucks to say that is it great I
was just did you have anything yes I
told you it happens a lot the rainbow
there was that so the final day of
shooting the final like after we shot
the entire movie we ended at maybe 9:00
in the morning yeah cuz every single we
would start on a Saturday and run all
the way through Wednesday and our
weekend would be stem Friday and no
Thursday and Friday so it would start
off at 7 a.m. and gradually get later
during the week so the final day we get
done at 9 a.m. we walk out the studio
and there's a double rainbow
double rainbow and that was just it just
capped off this the this most amazing
experience you know and it just was like
the heavens have aligned what no one
told you was that was a matte painting I
didn't want to spoil it until now
I want to say thank you sincerely so
much for coming in I cannot wait to
watch the movie at the premiere tonight
and it's I'm assuming the movies for
sale
was it already so i'm i hope it sells
immediately
that's my thank you right thank you all
so much for coming into the studio